on se comprend immédiatement je sais
tout de suite comme stéphane est content
pas content au premier regard des quand
j'entends couper les acteurs souvent je
suis pas le seul à couper première chose
paf on regarde papa c'est le pape a levé
3 est tout de suite et ont une demi
seconde
je sais si c'est formidable si c'est
dans la boîte
comme on dit ou s'il va y avoir un un
petit truc à refaire et le plus qu'à
refaire le temps long déplacement entre
l'endroit où je tournais la scène est
l'endroit où stéphane il ya huit mètres
quand j'arrive
généralement il n'a pas besoin de
commencer que je sais on tombe hors bord
et personne ne comprendrait langage
c'est stéphane me dit par exemple
valaisan dit j'ai trouvé que je vois là
mais je te dirai à massy isabelle
huppert qui joue donc une photographe
joue la photographe isabelle aride même
prénom mais autres professions
artistiques
pour isabelle huppert dans ce film une
célèbre photographe qui liront par en
permanence sur sur les champs de
batailles notamment en syrie en irak en
afghanistan et qui voit donc peu sa
famille et se fit bras compte c'est ça
le problème de communication
comment se sont passées les leçons de
rock'n'roll vincent mais je sais pas
pris de son cas mais non puisque vous
êtes avec le film c'est le personnage
prend des leçons dont je suis arrivé
qu'au niveau de rock'n'roll
c'est à dire extrêmement moyen âge de
tests danser toute façon parce que je
suis de nature assez optimiste donc
c'était assez bas pas facile parce que
le travail
on est peut-être très est jugé très
exigeant mais
mais je sais qu'il ya des scènes ou pas
qui sont très très motivé j'ai dû
pleurer qu'elle lesquels je vais pas te
veut pas tout dire le pas raconter
d'histoires on est mais il ya des scènes
où je vois un moment donné un moment
donné craque et est en fait c'est
tellement bien écrit c'est tellement
bien amener qu'on n'avait pas le choix
de pleurer pour vrai en fait et je sais
ce que c'est ce qu'il m'a dit d'elle à
pleurer toute une journée
mais oui voilà j'avais déjà j'avais déjà
doublé la voix d'une mouche avant voilà
c'était pas aussi glamour mais
bienvenue dans le grand journal
à mon avis pour antoine au mercy est bas
vous qui êtes un roi de l'impro françois
damiens qu'est ce que c'est de jouer
avec un grand scénario qu'est ce que ça
change ça change qui a pas grand chose à
faire en fait il suffit de faire ce
qu'on vous demandez moi thomas il va il
m'a impressionné il m'a envoûtée en fait
c'est j'avais rencontré il ya quelques
années
et puis moi ce que j'ai vraiment aimé à
travers tout c'est qu'il a voulu me
connaître en vêtements de faire le film
donc il est venu chez moi en belgique il
a rencontré ma famille mes amis
il ya venu chez moi en bretagne il et il
était là oui on a fait du catamar
ensemble on a profité de la vie vous
avez appris à mieux vous connaître vous
avez appris à mieux vous connaître
exactement ouais ouais c'est ça non mais
c'est vrai c'est non mais c'est
important parce que il m'est déjà arrivé
aussi sera un film d'arrivée
de dire bonjour chef d'écho en crawl
c'était le radiateur est ce que vous
pouvez nous le raconte et moi sommes des
combattants revenir à la télévision cela
fait trois ans depuis la fin de
desperate housewives je pense qu'il
était grand temps de revenir à la
télévision dans ce cas là c'est en fait
en coulisses d'une telenovela espagnol
danse est une comédie moi je joue la
diva d'une émission télé vision et mon
ex mari revient et il casse tout il
détruit tout sur son passage et moi
genre des gestes du fond du coeur etc
c'est drôle parce que nous devons
travailler ensemble nous devons nous en
bras lisez étendu devant être gentil
l'un envers l'autre c'est très dur
et voilà vous avez tout le casting est
complètement fou sur le choix c'est
marrant parce qu'on fait rien comment
enfin on fait rien comme les américains
en fait mais non en france on est
content de la télévision pour le cinéma
ils sont contents de quitter le cinéma
pour la télévision et c'est vrai si tu
fais une émotion ce soir ce serait
laquelle mélanie la canne à sucre est le
rôle de jeu sera bien évidemment la joie
et puis un peu peur quand même aussi
parce que c'est ma première montée des
marches
donc tout est possible moi je dans le
film suit peur mais alors ce soir je
suis joint à 200%
je suis sûr que les 7ème et a touché la
petite ado qui sommeille en vous mais je
suis tellement sensible mais je sais non
mais je pense pics à en blesser je le
pense vraiment jour que pixar aide les
enfants à devenir un peu plus adulte et
les adultes à tenir un peu plus enfantin
allo
il est dit que la romance plus pauvres
il